well how's this for uncomfortable
Orlando Bloom's not so smooth proposal
to Katy Perry it was really sweet he
asked me to marry him in a helicopter
he's pulling out this box that's too big
for his a coat pocket it rips his coat
pocket and his elbow goes into the
champagne and I'm like no I know you're
not doing anything Wow would you be
wearing those big headphones waiting
proposed well
[Music]
we learned a few things about the
soon-to-be mr. and mrs. bloom the first
is about that ring fans think looks like
the one
Orlando gave his ex Miranda Kerr did you
pick out your razor did he pick out the
ring voice my opinion that's the way to
go next the couple bonded over an
in-n-out burger he stole one off of my
table and he took it and I was like wait
oh you're so hot Katie gave no I do
details as she left Kimmel but she did
reveal one thing she does that kind of
noise her man so you've already thrown
all his stuff away so he's had a
toiletry bag for about ten years then
they went straight in the trash he was
very upset
I had like a full timeout
[Applause]
[Music]